sont partis
alors ils ont été souvent évacués ces
Ukrainiens
ne soit reprise par les par les
ukrainiens et c'est vrai que on a aussi
assisté après le départ des Russes a des
opérations de la police notamment pour
tenter de retrouver des collaborateurs
il y en a il y en a probablement plus
beaucoup dans cette ville désertée il y
a un mouvement contradictoire puisque
une partie de la population de Kerson
fuit on a vu des gens dans ce reportage
partir à bord de bus à peu près 100 à
150 personnes partent chaque jour il y a
aussi des trains qui partent tous les
deux jours lorsque c'est possible parce
que le réseau ferroviaire est parfois
bombardé c'est ce qui s'est produit il y
a quelques jours lorsque nous tournions
ce reportage et puis il y a aussi tout
Le blast de Carson c'est à dire tous ces
villages qui étaient sous le joug des
Russes pendant de longs mois qui
reprennent peu à peu vie et et là par
contre on a des populations qui
reviennent on a rencontré ceux qui sont
restés qui n'ont jamais quitté la zone
qui parfois ont vécu une année sans
électricité sans soi petit à petit à
certains nombres de dispensaires sont
réhabilités et petit à petit la vie
reprend son cours mais ça prend du temps
pour une population qui est souvent
traumatisée une population qui vit avec
le spectre de voir peut-être un jour les
Russes revenir parce que la situation
reste compliquée à Kerson c'est une
ville qui est sur le front et les Russes
ne sont pas loin toujours aussi
menaçants pour une population comme je
vous le disais traumatisée merci
beaucoup Karim Yahyaoui merci à vous en
direct de Carson